parlons si vous le voulez bien de cette
crise qui aujourd'hui une crise
diplomatique qui peut être va devenir
une crise migratoire mais on va le voir
elle se passe à la frontière entre la
turquie et l'europe vous avez que
plusieurs millions auprès de quatre
millions de réfugiés notamment syriens
sont en turquie la turquie jusqu'à
présent bloqué sa frontière mais pour se
venger avec toutes les guillemets qui
s'imposent de l'union européenne et de
l'otan qui ne soutiennent pas la turquie
en syrie contre la russie c'est assez
compliqué et bien erdogan a décidé
d'ouvrir ses frontières voire même de
faciliter l'arrivée jusqu'à aux
frontières européennes des migrants qui
sont actuellement en turquie pour
l'instant il y en a plusieurs milliers
qui sont massés à la frontière mais il
pourrait y en avoir bientôt des millions
c'est en tout cas la promesse du chef
d'état turc il l'a fait ce matin
conseil n 2 millions alors dans cette
circonstance très tendu un responsable
un commissaire européen vient de
déclarer que personne ne faisait chanter
l'union européenne emmanuel macron lui
dans un tweet publié hier soir affirme
le soutien de la france à la grèce et à
la bulgarie qui sont en première ligne
dans cette crise
et puis voici encore un élément apporté
au dossier
la question du jour sur le figaro.fr
craignez-vous un afflux de migrants
depuis la turquie comme en 2015
c'est oui à 90 %
partagez vous cette inquiétude périco
légasse je voudrais que les gens qui
nous ont expliqué il ya une quinzaine
d'années que monsieur erdogan était un
islamiste modéré et qu'il allait mettre
la turquie sous la voie du progrès et
dans une éventuelle intégration ils
viennent s'expliquer j'aimerais que les
gens qui ont soutenu les moments de
monde bagdad en 2003 viennent expliquer
vous connaissez les noms se sont tous
despars donc qu'est ce qu'on fait
attendez c'est coronavirus ou erdogan
ou est-ce qu'on en est effectivement là
je pense que l'union européenne si elle
veut prouver que l'europe existe tout
simplement doit réagir de façon
véhémente et virulente face à cette
menace de voyous ce type est un tyran
c'est un [ __ ] c'est une ordure et nous
autres démocraties qui représentera la
civilisation nous n'avons pas nous
laisser traiter comme ça par cette
espèce de satrapes ottoman voilà là je
trouve qu on touche le fond
alors on a des petites paroles l'europe
se laissera pas dicter voilà cette
menace là en plus ce sont des vies
humaines
il joue avec la détresse humaine
e-menaces évidemment la bulgarie et la
grèce qui vont être les premières
victimes sillage des frontières et on
sait que ce fou est capable de le faire
puisque c'est un c'est un homme qui est
capable de commettre les pires exactions
pour à peu pour appliquer son idéologie
je pense qu'aujourd'hui l'union
européenne doit prouver une fois où son
existence depuis 1957 qu'elle est
capable de résister à la barbarie
je tiendrai un militant européen
convaincu à ce moment là je suis pas sûr
qu'il se passe que ça aille dans ce sens
là parce qu'évidemment la question c'est
de savoir
ce qu'il faut faire avec ces migrants
qui sont massés à la frontière
les grecs en tout cas ce qu'on a pu
filmer manifeste de fortes réticences
voire même un rejet clair et net
regardez ces images elles sont tournées
à lesbos ou sept îles qui a déjà
accueilli un très grand nombre de
migrants et ce bateau de migrants ne
peut pas accoster parce que les
habitants de l'île le refuse
d'autres considèrent au contraire qu'il
faut'' accueillir ces migrants que c'est
même la seule solution c'est le point de
vue de jean luc mélenchon il exprimait
sur france inter que devons faire et
bien accueillir raisonnablement et
correctement ces pauvres gens qu'on a
lâché comme des animaux dans la campagne
en espérant ou qu'il meure ou qu'ils
disparaissent ou qu'il crée un problème
tels que ça dit ce look tout par
conséquent montrant monsieur erdogan que
nous sommes des puissances le rop
supérieure à sa violence et il ya que ça
à faire parce que sinon qu'est ce qu'on
fait on les rejette dans le camp de
monsieur erdogan on les jette à la mer
chez charal i7 propre des tragédies sic
a pas de solution mais que faut-il faire
il faut accueillir encore ou maintenant
dire c'est tout ça suffit on ne ferme
je pense qu'il y à une solution c'est
celle que l'union européenne n'a pas
voulu vraiment prendre depuis le début
c'est de créer des grands camps
d'accueil de migrants à la périphérie
c'est à dire sur ses frontières
le drame de toute cette histoire c'est
que ce qui se passe à lesbos est indigne
parce que le camp dans l'île de lesbos
est un camp qui défie toutes les
conditions des pires pays et on est dans
une situation pour ceux qui sont allés
les migrants qui sont allés ce beau
c'est à dire sur le territoire l'union
européenne vivent dans certaines des
ruelles du camp dans de pires conditions
que l'héroïne gars au bangladesh
donc la vraie question c'est qu'il faut
mettre effectivement un dispositif
d'urgence
il ne s'agit pas de laisser ces migrants
entrer sur le territoire de l'union
européenne
mais il s'agit de les accueillir il ya
des structures pour ça les quand on sait
faire bien évidemment c'est une notion
très délicate à manier
elle est très difficile mais entre
rejeter les gens allaient méditerranée
accepter la surenchère d'erdogan ou
risques et des complications politiques
énormes à l'intérieur du territoire
l'union européenne je ne vois pas
d'autres solutions il est temps que
l'union européenne s'équipe de
structures adéquates pour accueillir ces
gens qui sont des personnes humaines et
ensuite il va falloir pardonnez moi
l'expression trier comme ça s'est fait
dans tous les camps de réfugiés du monde
et il faudra à savoir qui est qui et
demandeurs d'asile légitime et qui ne
l'est pas il y as parmi ces gens
notamment le zodiaque qu'on a vu
énormément d'afghans il se trouve
coïncidence du calendrier qu'un accord
de paix vient d'être signée en
afghanistan entre les états unis et les
talibans voilà il faudra patienter il
faudra prendre du temps je ne vois pas
comment ça peut être réglé autrement
qu'avec une mécanique d'accueil qui
dépasse de loin les soi-disant hotspot
qu'on a fait aujourd'hui en grèce et
qu'on ne veut pas assumer et donc ceux
qui ne sont pas éligibles au droit
d'asile d'une loi ou d'une autre il
faudra les renvoyer je vais prendre un
exemple qui est celui de la suisse et il
s'agit pas du tout de faire de la suisse
un modèle à part que momo un demandeur
présumé demandeur d'asile arrivent en
suisse dès qu'il pose le pied sur le
territoire leur tour lui ai proposé
immédiatement leur tour lui est proposé
et il primo retour lui ai proposé
et bien voilà des choses qu'il faudrait
pouvoir faire sur le territoire de
l'union européenne
et ensuite mettre en oeuvre évidemment
pas ce que proposait c'est une chose
mettre en oeuvre sans aucune autre on
vous offrira le tgv de retour moi je
suis quand même beaucoup plus sévère que
vous parce que la seconde non pas que
vous quand parce que cela sape ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui avec sous la pression
du gouvernement s'apparente à un acte de
guerre cela s'apparente à une invasion
une invasion qui n'est plus une invasion
simplement humanitaire mais une invasion
agressive et d'ailleurs on voit que en
grèce vous avez maintenant des
échauffourées entre les migrants et les
forces de l'ordre règne c'est ce que
nous le dit si choquantes ont forcé
l'entrée dans un pays c'est une invasion
c'est une invasion à cette innovation et
c'est une guerre et donc nous sommes là
potentiellement dans une situation de
guerre est dans une situation de guerre
on ne peut pas raisonner comme monsieur
mélenchon en disant il faut les soeurs
laissez venir des envahisseurs roulant
ou alors dans ce cas là ont renoncé en
fait et on fait on fait le jeu de la
collaboration est ce que je ne veux pas
croire de monsieur mélenchon
je vois bien qu'il veut qu'il le qu'il
qu'il brandit l'indult naturellement un
humanitarisme v on ne peut pas à chaque
fois maintenant brandir cette
humanitarisme qui est notre marque de
faiblesse et qui est la marque de
faiblesse de l'union européenne elle
même donc je pense que l'union
européenne aujourd'hui hélas à
s'affirmer comme elle n'a jamais su le
faire et là s'affirmer face à erdogan
qui naturellement s'essuie les pieds
très régulièrement sur sur ce que nous
sommes aujourd'hui peut-être d'ailleurs
en menaçant le elle même de renvoyer en
turquie pas mal de c2c turcs eux qui
sont en europe et en france pourquoi pas
pourquoi est ce que nous ne l'aurions
pas nous-mêmes à faire effectivement
cette réciprocité désagréable de dire
que si vous avez s'il ya des turcs en
europe ils n'ont qu'à peut-être que qu'à
retourner s'il ne sont pas simplement
français à retourner dans leur pays je
ne sais pas c'est une option président
envisage à envisager et en tout cas de
rappeler que l'europe paie 8 milliards
je crois donne 8 milliards ar de gand à
la turquie afin qu'ils qui précisément
qu'il maîtrise de cette émigration des
plus de des près de 4 millions de
syriens qui sont sur son sol et donc il
ya d'abord ces question d'imposer n'y a
dedans donc d'un rapport de force et
puis de la question essentielle dans le
fond qui est une question beaucoup plus
politique et diplomatique
c'est de savoir si vraiment la turquie
encore quelque chose à faire dans l'otan
qui est vraiment le club ddd du monde
libre si je puis dire on voit bien que
aujourd'hui lily à une incongruité à
voir que le l'otan accueille aujourd'hui
d'un pays qui d'abord occupe une partie
d'un pays de l'union européenne je veux
parler de chypre et là tout le monde
s'en fiche et qui aujourd'hui maintenant
menace la structure même de l'union
européenne et sa fragilité parce que
naturellement nous savons tous que
l'union européenne est particulièrement
fragile de ces deux de ces invasions là
et que l'opinion publique de toute façon
ne le tolérera pas donc on en est à
cette épreuve de force et cette épreuve
de force et ne passe pas par des deux
parents dessinant des petits coeurs et
en faisant venir des bateaux elle passe
maintenant par des parts d'aidé
les mots des solutions de réciproque des
mesures de réciprocité face à cette
intransigeance de ce tyran là alors
c'est aussi le point de vue de nicole
qui nous dit qu'est ce que l'union
européenne attend pour renvoyer des
militaires aux frontières grec et
bulgare pour les aider donc antoine
billot nous dit que la réaction est trop
tardive qu'il aurait fallu agir dès 2015
une récurrente reparti 20 depuis quelque
temps a contrario avec respect c'est le
nom de ce cet internaute c'est son
pseudonyme plus exactement pour une fois
je suis d'accord avec ce que dit
mélenchon
et vous richard bride en fait on a
plusieurs niveaux de lecture sur ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui en turquie et ça
mérite un petit peu quand même d'être
d'être bien c'est pareil moi je vous
rejoins sur ce qui est aujourd'hui
l'attitude d'erdogan qui est en fait une
menace clairement il utilise une espèce
de bombes ce n'est pas la première fois
d'ailleurs non ce n'est pas la première
fois mais là c'est la première fois où
la menace en fête prend une tournure qui
est un peu plus grave que d'habitude et
bon sens qui a à la fin de l'agression à
la fois du chantage
il ya beaucoup de choses qui sont
insupportables et je pense
qu'effectivement il doit y avoir une
réponse à cette stratégie politique qui
est celle d'erdogan
je n'oublie pas néanmoins que s'il a
aujourd'hui cette capacité c'est parce
qu'on lui a confié une partie de cette
capacité quand je dis on c'est l'europe
qui lui a délégué une partie de la
gestion de la crise des réfugiés
qu'aujourd'hui c'est un petit peu le
retour de boomerang avec un président
qui utilise vallat qui manipulent
instrumentalise à des fins agressives
cette situation je n'oublie pas non plus
que cette situation elle n'est aussi là
tout de suite de la situation en syrie
sur laquelle on peut dire que les
grandes puissances ne se sont jamais
entendus pour essayer de faire cesser
réellement les combats et de remettre un
peu de deux au moins de paix de cessez
le feu ou au moins de cohérence
politique là dedans on en est là parce
que quoi parce qu'à un moment donné
vladimir poutine et bachar el assad sont
en train de reconquérir une partie du
pays parce qu'à côté il y a eu les
agissements de la turquie qui voulait
reconquérir une autre partie avec un
peuple kurde qui étaient au milieu et
qui est bon très bien mais la situation
aujourd'hui elle est internationale et
elle est en syrie et ne réglons pas la
situation en syrie et on aura de toute
manière un problème avec les réfugiés
die
heures jeudi prochain erdogan se rend en
russie pour voir poutine et ils vont
bien évidemment se partager quelque
chose quoi je ne sais pas mais au final
et c'est là où je reviens moi je partage
tout mais néanmoins parmi ces personnes
qui sont déplacés on a des personnes qui
subissent depuis des années des
bombardements des faits de guerre et qui
sont aujourd'hui ma c'est là où ils
peuvent
qu'est ce qu'on fait on n'a rien fait au
niveau européen parce que l'europe d'un
côté ne veut pas accueillir ces
personnes ont dit qu'on va faire des
hotspots lèvera le hotspot seulement à
rien ça a été des conditions qui ont été
ratés que n'ont pas du tout été mis en
place
est ce qu'on est prêt à faire ce que
vous avez dit même en dehors de l'europe
je ne suis même pas sûr qu'en ce moment
mais il faudrait le vrai courage et
peut-être ra c'est là où je suis moi le
descriptif par rapport à ce que vous
dites et même par rapport à maquereau et
je rejoins mélenchon moi je m'interroge
quand même sur le sort de ces personnes
qui sont à un moment donné ballotté de
partout
qu'est ce qu'on va faire de ces
personnes certaines effectivement on va
dire que ce soit en europe ou world
europe
on va étudier leur situation certains
auront la possibilité de déposer
effectivement une demande pour devenir
réfugiés parce que au titre de leur
parcours de leur histoire ce tas et les
autres on les renvoie en iran voix ou
guillaume roquette en syrie on les
renvoie ou en syrie mais ou en semaines
en syrie mais où
si au moment de la sphère kurdes l'union
européenne l'otan avait pris ses
responsabilités alors en marquant un
territoire délimité un territoire neutre
dans lequel on aurait pu accueillir ces
réfugiés en les rentrant chez eux
mais une fois nous lisons ces trois-là
quotas alors évidemment colère soir on
va pas on va mal ne va pas l'aimer
tranchée un cabanon entre voilà voilà
mais par contre il ya ce sujet par
contre on arrive à militarise une zone
un peu de la nabe la bulgarie et la
grèce
on les reçoit à titre provisoire et on
fait en sorte que les moyennes en accord
oui on est d'accord mais là oui mon top
sur un organe au passage sa jambe était
même une chose c'est qu'il n'y a pas
simplement que l'europe qui pourrait
recevoir ces gens là il ya également
tous les pays arabes alentours qui se
garde bien d'ouvrir leurs portes et on
pourrait quand même se poser la question
de savoir s'il n'y a pas une solidarité
de louvain en l'occurrence qui
permettrait plutôt un avis à l'arabie
saoudite notamment pas tous ces pays
beaucoup plus riche que dans l'idéal
mais oui mais pourquoi ça ne vient même
pas 10
alors que je méritais de l'arabie
saoudite et c'est long mais j'entends
bien exaltant bien là mais moi je ne me
convient pas je ne se sont tout ça ce
sont des rapports de force vous voyez
bien qu'à chaque fois dans l'europe
semoule et chine et à chaque fois c'est
l'europe et l'europe recul et si on ne
peut pas ensuite se désole de voir qu'il
ya une montée du populisme en europe ce
qui est une vérité et de ne pas
comprendre les causes de cette montée du
populisme qui est de 7 chez serge de
faiblesse intrinsèque de l'europe et
c'est vrai que les pc conflit en syrie
et vous aurez encore des rennais qui ont
quand même là aussi pardonnez moi
d'après ce que j'ai pu lire il n'y a pas
tant de si rien que ça dans les arrivées
en ce moment de pure qui il y a
énormément d'afghans il y adeux
énormément de bangladeshis lie à des
pakistanais
donc voilà donc il faut faire attention
en l'occurrence bien peut-être que les
syriens ne sont qu'une minorité et
peut-être sont-ils ceux qui mériteraient
le plus sûr d'être accueillis dans des
familles voulaient juste et pour les
autres pays il ya matière à entreprendre
des retours merci on change complètement
de sujets si vous le voulez bien nous
revenons en france pour parler du 49-3
vous avez cet article de la constitution
qui permet d'adopter de fer adopté sans
vote un projet de loi pour autant qu'il
n'y ait pas de motion de censure pour
renverser le gouvernement
cela paraît peu probable puisque la
majorité en marche soutient ce projet le
49-3 d'habitude c'est plutôt pour calmer
les